I don't care what we have to do I want
to win if you're not first you're not
nothing
al-jazeera's investigative unit is
locking away a box of drugs banned in
sport we've just bought them from
medical professionals who say they work
with top-level athletes doctors chemists
chiropractors those are the individuals
distributing the performance-enhancing
substances to athletes
working with a British athlete we
infiltrate a network who claim their
scientific expertise can cheat the
system months our hidden cameras capture
what athletes call the dark side the
secret world of doping we catch the
chemical mastermind and hear about
players he claims he's doped to fame and
extraordinary claims that raise
questions whether an American sporting
hero Peyton Manning is linked to
performance-enhancing drugs as long as
they know what the testing procedure is
they'll always be able to beat it the
only way that you will ever get caught
is by an investigation
the best way to understand the dark side
of sport is to meet an athlete whose
beam air and back there you go driving
driving driving transition there we go
good job good job good arms good drive I
have to chasing the dark side the way I
chased it have jumped on planes I cross
borders I smuggle drugs I've chased the
best I work with the best
Jim Montgomery was once the fastest man
in the world
Tim Montgomery's in Lane five
only five men have ever run faster come
on you really go miss Kahn you gotta be
ready look at here look at the man you
can't pay attention a long time a poor
kid from South Carolina
Tim learned early on about getting an
edge in local street races against older
bigger runners
somebody's got was souped up
when I meet my souped-up they may drink
some a shot of liquor hit a lot of
cocaine and jump on the line so that was
my first experience I seen someone try
to connect a self up so it started there
their hunger that feeling that fast
which it started right there
that hunger never left him to stay ahead
in a sport where a fraction of a second
means everything Tim turned to
performance-enhancing drugs in 2005 he
was caught banned from athletics for two
years and stripped of his world record I
wanted to win
I wanted the glory I felt as a kid
beating the older guys I wanted that
fill it and just like everything is
undone I got caught these days Tim
coaches young athletes stressing the
value of clean sport you're here and
just be patient boom boom boom and then
slowly start bringing head around and
get us through your run honestly I'm
telling you I said let's take it easy
Liam Collins is a British athlete who's
now writing a book about Tim's life one
of Tim's oddest stories is how he first
got hold of drugs he says he found a
doctor in the Bahamas willing to supply
and Tim celebrated with a fish dinner
we had went to Goldie's fish fry and I
was like man that's the first time I had
read snap my wrists nothing I like man I
wish I can get some of this fish back
and that gave him the idea for smuggling
the drugs back home we could freeze it
and it'd stay frozen the whole trip so
didn't me been a street dude I took the
fuels back with me but we took a bottle
of testosterone back with us - yeah and
I we took it inside to fish he and Liam
have much in common
both men have run into trouble and found
a fresh start on the track
for a while Liam went into property
development promising high returns he
couldn't deliver investors lost millions
and Liam was banned as a company
director
Liam's now back on track in every way
competing again and looking for new
challenges so we had a proposal
helped us to investigate doping in sport
he's perfectly placed to go undercover
by claiming to be an athlete desperate
to qualify for the Rio Olympics it's a
closed business you know amongst people
who are in the know and here was an
opportunity for me personally to be the
guy to go undercover and make a change
our first task was to test out Liam's
cover story
with the doctor who allegedly sold
banned drugs to Tim Montgomery inside
the airport the Hall of Champions honors
the island nation's greatest athletes
pride of place goes to the Golden Girls
the hundred meter relay team who
triumphed in the 2000 Olympics in Nassau
we made an appointment for Liam with the
same doctor Tim says he went to in his
bag a hidden camera three
dr. Cyprian Strawn is a respected figure
here a one time he sat on a caribbean
wide anti-doping board for bodybuilding
is there anyone else with me speaking to
on the island number I don't know if
he's gonna have you tends to be
aggressive aggressive like in general
just to anyone you know ingress it in
terms of
I don't care that you wanted I get it oh
right okay okay I see what you say
and then he gets his pain out he says
well first of all I I just do the stuff
anymore that's pretty much an admission
that used to straight away there's a guy
called dr. Fox dr. Nicholas Fox who I've
got his number got his cell phone works
it we've got the Medical Center number
so the chase continues interested in the
hormone Evo incident testosterone
these are all synthetic versions of the
body's natural hormones they build up
strength and stamina and they're banned
by the governing bodies of most sports I
might be paranoid thinking that a lot of
athletes are on this oh do you know that
well yeah every tiny cold metals do you
credit yet well with the Golden Girls I
want
through that patient really help them
we've got our mind when we contacted dr.
Fox he told us he'd lied to Liam can't
get banned drugs and has never seen
professional athletes dr. Strawn
categorically denied supplying drugs to
anyone and has never been charged with
any wrongdoing connected to Tim
Montgomery
no one has alleged that the golden girls
used drugs when we contacted them
Pauline Davis Thompson told us she
condemned athletes who dope as morally
warped and gutless and said she's never
met dr. Fox our next step with Liam was
to see if his cover story would lead us
to top-level athletes on the dark side
my name is Lynn Collins currently six
times European masters m35 400 meter
hurdles and 100-meter hurdles champion
over the next few months our team worked
on pinpointing people with possible
connections to doping and steering Liam
towards them my weakest area at the
moment I would say is my strength and
conditioning liam again introduces
himself as an athlete wanting a last
shot at Olympic glory yeah I'm just
gonna put one last lane in a little bit
more emotive to let him know that I am
at the point where I'm ready to do
whatever it takes really he spoke to
wrestlers runners physios trainers
doctors he can give me a call and much
appreciate it I'm in Washington DC at
the moment eventually we made a
breakthrough beyond athletics to the
world of North American sport
Vancouver is where Canada hosted the
2010 Winter Olympics
Liam spoken by phone to a pharmacist
here Chad Robertson he claims he's
already worked with top athletes people
oh yeah and no one's got caught because
a system is so easy to beat and it still
is that's a sad fact I can take a guy
with average genetics and I can make the
world champion I can I got like I can
get anything I wanna get like a Russian
tank through the border here if I wanted
to after that phone call Liam and Chad
arranged to meet Chloe up really good
the oxidative free radicals like nos and
Ross they come in there they destroy the
the cell membrane and then you get
dysfunctional mitochondria very common
in athletes will use some permit as well
its carbon sixty you can look into a
dead US military's these know of the
record you're a smart guy you just keep
your mouth shut
well that's basically it if you don't
sell your secrets over coffee Chad
Robertson said he'd create a program
covering diet legal supplements and the
dark side
that included drugs banned in
professional sports like growth hormone
known as GH and other drugs which reduce
fat and increase muscle rolling in GRS
2029
I'd love to deal with stuff to see if it
I can do it no I'll hook it with the
broker appointment right
he is military construct all this get a
destroyer yeah
one reason Chad Robertson is so open is
because he wants to involve Liam in a
proposed and legitimate business venture
called promed he gave Liam their
presentation promed will treat athletes
who don't want to rely on their team
doctors the promed presentation already
features some American football players
they hope Liam can bring in European
soccer stars another partner in promed
is Brandon split sir
he's a naturopath doctor which means
he's medically trained although not an
MD
so this is going to be to give yourself
an IV 101 am i eating people on a
Thursday
Heinemann who you were with before
there's high-level sportsmen usually
through the NFL in the u.s. that's kind
of a market that we're going after
Vancouver is in the only province in
Canada where all naturopaths can
prescribe drugs doctor split sir listed
medicines for depression sleep disorder
fertility problems Liam never claimed to
have the same drugs can enhance
performance HCG is no problem the
quality was the other one I think so as
long as I've got a prescription I can
actually buy with it really excellent
elements for fertility specifically HCV
right you say this is for my fertility
my wife and I are trying but my
testosterone levels which I was saying
essentially if we start mini playing
stuff but we could actually get rid of
the medical records
put it this way I'm not really writing
anything now if you want to really go
black off so to speak I can just
document everything not in this chart
but on my own chart and if somebody ever
comes sniffing for it it's very easy to
just delete and say no this is the real
chart
there's the deeply if say water comes
sniffing around wada is the world
anti-doping agency it determines which
drugs are banned in most sports and how
to test for them both splat sir and
Robertson praised another partner in
their new probe adventure who they
called a genius at outwitting water
if I ever died that's who I want you to
go to the only guy I trust he flies at
people's homes like Mike Tyson he takes
care of Mike and a few other big do it
really big out is he still to this day
felt the best NFL athlete that ever
existed athletically he is soul right is
Siri Wow he's taking smart drugs to a
whole new level someone who's taken
drugs to a new level with someone we
needed to meet
our hidden cameras are set up waiting
for this man
he's a doctor of pharmacy
Charlie sly
and he doesn't waste time before he
dives into the dark side and give you
some user now is this Delta to stuff
this this like this is February but
it'll be great for you for strength
gains all week there's a bunch of
football players and tankers and a bunch
of baseball players taken to and it was
recently added to the MLB bandless
major league baseball added delta ii by
name but as a steroid it was already
banned in baseball and football inside
charlie slice apartment liam discovers
his fridge is full of drugs including a
half filled syringe which sly offers for
immediate use now well I know this is
all full of yeah you should've been
spanked instantly then a we should
notice that 10-15 percent increases Wow
Liam declines the offer saying he wants
to read up on Delta 2 so takes a syringe
away it's one of many designers steroids
available online a bottle cost less than
$30
when we got back to his flat he pulls
out this from the fridge he's like yeah
there you go you can you can have it now
if you want this comes from a website he
says that it's the only website on the
internet that sells this stuff but
Dustin Keller buys all their stock
Dustin Keller is best known as the
college football player who became
famous overnight in the 2008 combine the
trials for top NFL clubs the footage
shows how Dustin Keller ran caught and
jumped his way through in a way that's
rarely been matched while Charlie sly
treats Liam sore arm with electrical
pulses not drugs
he claims he doped Dustin Keller to fame
he says they're at high school together
where Charlie experimented with a range
of drugs so when you combine delay test
yeah we just stopped no stuff except for
testosterone beginner or something good
enough window he stopped that's awesome
like to Dustin Keller's performance at
the combine and him a multi-million
dollar contract with the New York Jets
you just used altitude that's a wasn't a
quad so you think that all the way back
yeah mm thing yeah I mean maybe this is
2006 Wow
most recently Keller played for the
Miami Dolphins until he was sidelined
through injury we are starting Keller
for a response about his alleged
involvement with Charlie sly but he
didn't reply nor did Mike Tyson charlie
slice claims would involve many other
top players but his most astonishing
allegation concerns an icon of American
sport and his wife come in after hours
all the time we would be sending
growth-hormone all the time everywhere
the Al Jazeera investigative team is
back in Vancouver we've devised a cover
story for a British athlete Liam Collins
that qualify for the Olympics
he's willing to cross to the dark side
of sport and dope himself up
a pharmacist Chad Robertson appears
convinced he's devised a sophisticated
program of cutting-edge science drugs
and treatments a mix of legal and banned
none of which Liam will take our hidden
cameras are set up
you wouldn't be doing like 10 injections
a day in some cases Wow
okay hormonal enhancement now we're
gonna get into the batch right so Chad
explains they'll give me in prescription
drugs falsely claiming he's suffering
from exhaustion low fertility patient
complaints is a certain type of good not
as a fatigue lack of libido energy so
we're going to definitely basically use
AC cheating klonopin to target those
areas right away the other areas I'm
going to do I'm gonna increase your
growth hormone level to nightshift
levels drastically through three ways
IFL or three modified GRF 129 and epimer
all these are all drugs known as
peptides which spike performance and aid
recovery they're widely available online
with a disclaimer saying for medical
research
and not for human consumption first for
six weeks I'd be furious if I don't see
massive changes yeah I want massive
changes pertinent
he claims to have already helped
American football player Mike Neal who
also appears in the presentation for
Robertson's new sports medicine company
Neal won a Super Bowl ring in 2011
Lionel there's a great story we drop
this bad way those are the Green Bay
Packers we changed his position from all
defensive linemen to linebacker his
salary with us went from making four
hundred thousand dollars a year to two
million dollars a year and four years
that's results with his Packers teammate
Clay Matthews Robertson claims he helped
in a different way the NFC Championship
game is Green Bay and Oh Seattle I had
Clay Matthews was badly injured we sent
some narcotics and kill the pains barely
get up out of bed later Robertson named
the drug as percocet which isn't banned
but should only be prescribed by a
doctor
neither Mike Neil nor Clay Matthews
replied to our request for comment about
Chad Robertson's claims at their next
meeting outside a Sports Complex Chad
Robertson tells Liam his supply of drugs
is on its way some are coming from
across the border in the US from a
secretive online source who won't reveal
his location or his real name he's known
only as Thomas Mann who's Thomas Mann
smart guy is he a mess it's already been
contact I don't want you to contact me
yeah you said that 5th time maybe I
don't you meditate on your phone he will
start pulling everything on you to see
where your credit cards being everything
like that
yeah ok let Brandon do it yeah you
obviously know what I mean
I know exactly the phone he'll be the
fall guy hopefully night
his fall guy is Brandon splat sir and
naturopath doctor and one of Robertsons
business partners some of the drugs he
brings us on illegal as hard drugs are
but they're not approved for human
consumption and that's making him
nervous just so doesn't drink back to me
basically the peptides because I didn't
get into the state so they got held at
the border I was kind of freaked out
these ones didn't actually cross myself
put it this way it was [ __ ] out of me
to take this across the border because
that kind of just wrote a lot we've
locked all these drugs away preserving
the evidence of Liam's passport to the
dark side
neither Brandon's Blitzer nor Chad
Robertson provided us with any comment
I'm assured loves bus how you can you do
what you must
you it will
it was time to meet Charlie sly again we
wanted to test his doping expertise and
his level of connections he proved his
link to one sportsman very quickly
waiting at his building is a baseball
player
Taylor tea garden tea garden to deep
right-field that finds a gap Taylor tea
garden has played in Chicago
Texas New York and Baltimore and won an
Olympic bronze it seems Charlie's guided
him on a mix of keen and banned
substances including the steroid Delta
to two weeks
Wright had a test four weeks after my
last administration ever and I was also
taking peptides too but they were all
urine tests no blood to us
so they're not doing blood tests do they
do they do but uh once a year maybe
twice a most yeah some peptides leave
the body in hours others last days so
unless players are tested soon after
taking these banned drugs they have a
good chance of getting away with it we
asked Taylor Teegarden for a response
but he didn't offer one Mitch's baseball
had no steroids policy up until 2003 so
in the 1990s guys were so yeah hitting
so many home runs the owners did not
want these guys to be drug tested they
loved all the home runs
the drug abuse that led to decades of
baseball being known as the steroid era
also produced bigger faster players more
exciting games and revived the waning
popularity of the sport so how much is
the game cleaned up I believe that at a
minimum 20% of the 40-man roster players
are using performance-enhancing
substances and I mean that's a
conservative number from the information
I gathered over the years Eddie
Dominguez should know for six years
catching the dopers was part of his job
with MLB's investigation unit so that
would mean that they should be a 100
ball players that test positive and they
don't more than 8,000 tests were done
last season only 10 resulted in players
being disciplined speaking to sources
that were chemists the chemists always
say that it's a cat-and-mouse game as
long as they know what the testing
procedure is they'll always be able to
beat it
he needs a little break he's tired he's
not as young as you making me blush over
here thank you these days Eddie has more
time to play baseball with his son he
was forced out of his job last year when
MLB restructured his unit he wasn't
surprised and he says one of MLB vice
presidents made his view clear from the
start I remember vividly the first day
that I was there he approached me and
asked me if I was crazy to join the
Department of Investigations nobody in
baseball wants you you were basically
forced on to baseball and I respectfully
said to him if they come here to do
something that is important and make it
an even playing field for everybody
involved but having spent six years
there I think it's basically the bottom
line like any corporation it's there to
make money
and all we were doing is adding bad
press to Major League Baseball let's go
over the whole routine just like you
were like six years old all over again
let me know when you're ready okay here
we go to an two hands baby you got it
ready all right here we go
I believe that our investigations put
fear into some players but they'll
always find a way as always a chemist's
there's always a doctor they'll find a
way around in reply the MLB said it was
players not owners who resisted drug
testing they called Eddie Dominguez
account patently untrue and said the
Investigations Unit was launched
voluntarily and enthusiastically they
described baseball as a leader in the
fight against performance-enhancing
drugs back in Texas the pharmacist
Charlie sly named more sportsmen he
claims are linked to Delta 2 in baseball
and football
he says he coached them on what to take
and how to avoid testing positive in a
series of conversations Criss crossing
Texas we primed Liam with questions to
dig into the claims howard once you've
set him off easy like a maintenance
things
he's somebody that you cannot overwhelm
the stuff
you just make sure you have like
everything in bags he knows to take
stuff twice a day the news I just have
my teacher back to me what did he notice
it is hitting with the D - yeah I think
maybe just some more explosiveness he
had a couple years were here just in
time
Lancel seeing I see before Ryan
Zimmerman Bufo for all the day how long
you known Ximena six years
see how the d20 yeah what does he think
of the d2 does this job if you think
that was the moment our lab 19 sometimes
oh my god you still you should yeah and
Harrison will go all the way if it
stands will long display in Super Bowl
history here the Jeter says
know what does he do oh he's beast
really yes he's come up I play for he
plays for the Steelers he's been out for
a while by him as well yeah it's in the
d2 club yeah he takes it each of Ryan
Howard Ryan Zimmerman and James Harrison
emphatically denies taking Delta 2 or
any PD and say whoever claims that is
lying
James Harrison added he's never failed a
test for banned substances
if anyone says what about testosterone
what's your typical answer you don't
need a period thing adults - sunda has
just taken every day like they refuse to
stop really because like the biggest
hard head maybe bank near the wall is
loose and that's picked up by Mike Neil
he's having a heck of a game for the
Packer
Charlie sly claimed Mike Neil was a good
friend and through him he'd met several
other Green Bay Packers players last
year I went out to Green Bay for like
six weeks s that Mike stuff up but then
like he was certain sorry bring
everybody
I'm gonna go joking more than half the
team starting to come by
oh yeah like here such as pant burgers
julia's Baptist he's gonna take it all
the way
so I would do everything
usually I'd like Mike Neil's house or
Julia's house
what's Julia's like is really is he
pretty receptive to all this stuff yeah
he's all terms like 30 cents how does he
plan to detune does he like it
yeah but he doesn't take it that often
mama taken two days a week or four
disrepair
he's already big
I probably talk to
already directed them all up I already
turned to the back tandem but they've
been good about the adults as soon as I
could just tell them where to order I
didn't have to get involved
the quarterback is in trouble and Clay
Matthews is gonna get there
he's got the sack the years of Clay
Matthews is yeah I just got a text from
him oh yeah
so he plays my friend Mike Neil he wants
tore it all like in in a world form
what's the benefit of turtle
it's a powerful anti-inflammatory
where's he getting problems with his
ankle long-term use of toradol is so
dangerous that is banned in some
countries all they're not the US Charlie
sly says Matthews is also using newer
drugs to boost his hormone levels and
avoid detection
he takes I'm the Marlon
I don't think that he takes a stage
anymore just because of the potential
for blood test what all the D to Z on
the D - no I didn't want to like push
the envelope with him because he's kind
of behind profile guy so unless he like
unless he asked for more and I gotta try
and push it on Mike Neil Julius Peppers
and Flay Matthews didn't respond to our
request for comment neither did the
Green Bay Packers Charlie sly raised one
final astonishing question about one of
the most beloved of American sportsman
fans consider Peyton Manning one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time at 39
who now plays for the Denver Broncos
battle character and that father and
husband mentality is very important to
me I love being Manning gives us hope
gives us hope
Peyton Manning's career almost ended
through injury in 2010 while playing for
the Indianapolis Colts Charlie sly
claims he was part of a medical team
that helped Manning recover
what's he like as a person okay these
really cool if you just sit down
the first time I met it was like gyres
and it's like you know I really
appreciate you guys working with me
sorry real genuine the Guyer Institute
in Indianapolis offers a range of
genuine anti-aging treatments we've
confirmed Charlie sly worked in their
pharmacy in 2011 that was also the
season Peyton Manning miss through
injury I did it part of my training at
the Guyer Institute which is like this
anti-aging clinic in Indiana him and his
wife would come in after hours of godís
so one thing that Gaia does is he
dispenses drugs out of his office which
physicians can do in the nine states
it's just not very many of them do it
and all the time we would be sending
Ashley Manning drugs like that growth
hormone all the time everywhere in
Florida
you'll never be under Peyton's name
there would always be on her name
worsening everywhere
growth hormone is banned in the NFL the
Players Union held up the introduction
of tests for three years since random
sampling began in 2014
no one's tested positive Charlie sly
appeared knowledgeable about the drug he
knows it's severely restricted even as a
legal medication juice is one of the few
drugs enjoy all enjoyed not prescribed
off-label that's three indications we
checked that with one of America's
leading experts Professor Alan Rogal is
an endocrinologist he spent 40 years
treating children with growth hormone
deficiency and has advised government
and sporting bodies on the drugs misuse
he confirmed growth hormone for adults
can only be prescribed for three
conditions one is growth hormone
deficiency either carrying over from a
child or an adult who's had a serious
condition of a pituitary tumor surgery
or radiation therapy in that area
the other two are short bowel syndrome
which is simply bowel cut out from a
patient who's had cancer or another
bowel disease
the third is HIV wasting so these are
people who have HIV and not doing well
they are wasting away those are the only
three that are appropriate indications
for growth hormone in an adult patient
in response to Charlie sli's claims
Peyton Manning's agent said the
insinuations being peddled are baseless
and absolutely false Peyton Manning has
never done what this person is
suggesting the treatment he received at
the Guyer Institute was provided on the
advice of his physician and with the
knowledge of teen doctors and trainers
he received these treatments during
regular business hours all right after
his team's afternoon practices
any medical treatment received by Ashley
is a private matter of hers her doctor
and her family any medication shipped to
her was prescribed by her doctor and
taken solely by her for aljazeera
or its source to imply anything else is
outrageous and wrong so what about dr.
Dale gaya who prescribed and shipped the
growth hormone many drugs can be used
off-label if a doctor believes as
evidence it will help with a different
illness but that's not the case with
growth hormone there are codes that say
it is illegal there are punishments
including jail for prescribing it or for
trafficking in it very clearly it is
illegal to prescribe it it is one of the
only drugs that I know of that is in
that way off-label prescription illegal
not just not a good idea it's illegal
and if you had one of these three
serious conditions where would you go
for treatment and would that be an
anti-aging clinic
never the growth hormone deficiency
would be in an endocrinologist who takes
care of adults the HIV wasting would be
an infectious disease clinic
perhaps a gastroenterology clinic and a
short gut certainly would be
gastroenterology gut surgery type
clinics they would not be anti-aging
clinics some doctors in anti-aging
clinics who've supplied
performance-enhancing drugs have been
fined and jailed their clinic shut down
charlie slice claims if true suggests
dr. gaya was widely prescribing growth
hormone
I would see patients with ham from
Harlan and they're there for the day I
would work in his pseudo pharmacy
yeah I'm surprised at his places have
been shut down Gary's but really yeah
dr. gaya didn't respond to our request
for a comment Charlie sly said his
statements about athletes were false and
incorrect
new drug scandals in sport are emerging
all the time the Olympics are months
away and as our investigation has proved
there are plenty of doctors and chemists
taking doping to a whole new level
it's no different than a drug smuggler
if who's tunnel gets found today
tomorrow you'll have a plane the day
after that submarine at the gaff letes
are the same way the protocol that they
had given if they follow it they'll
never get quiet for me it was just to
finally drive the debate away from all
they do in it then maybe we can finally
evolve to the next and the most
important part of the debate what are we
gonna do about it
it becomes addiction that feeling that
drive that will that won't that need
it's not worth which you gotta live with
the rest of your life
by doing it dirty